bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti e sono
uomini che sono poi ieri siamo con lo
step one nazionale perché avete già
letto dal titolo stiamo per fare una
partita dove giocheremo solo cercando di
fare cose legali su gta 5 cioè possibile
lo stesso mi ha detto che per partire
dovevo farlo a venire a forte zanchu
d'ora le persone di me in frettissima la
vedi la minima pam si ok tu devi fare la
reazione a questo veicolo
inizierai a rispettare le leggi guidando
questo veicolo e lo dovrei far atterrare
all'aeroporto
vabbè andiamo in modo normale ma sei
lontanissimo questo è non ci posso fare
nulla purtroppo lo mettere da parte i
nuovi ti muovi ti arrivando minute 50
manca perché io non c'è il passo che ci
sono le stelle già in partenza e un
getto addio cos'è sta roba
crede che sia lario più grande che
rimane questo susciti tanto costa sta
roba è non mi ricordo tipo 5 milioni
come hai fatto a prenderli ma è enorme
lo so e tu vai vai vai pure seguito che
non certo privato mi fido 1 fai bene tu
e non credo che gente sia veloce come se
madonna mentre ma esiste veramente
storico credo di sì ma è veramente
troppo grande e pazzesco madonna e
giganti si muovo l'alto ti prego
lanciare i player addirittura madonna
carrello dentro inside è l'ex co
mamma mia aprire il vano bombe cosa
ragazzi
raga no ti prego ti spegne il motore non
posso praticamente fisicamente non lo
considera oddio ma mi è partito un
motore mi è partito molto cosa non mi è
partito tutto
la ragazza planando sto provando ma
partito giu il carrello l'ho fatto in
flight simulator so come fare
atterraggio d'emergenza a tema della
canzone che non posso parlare se una
parte ma esplode moderno e tutto aiuto
ci voglio credere che l'autostrada ma
lei sono enormi sono più grosse di tutte
e due con siena 10 che cosa fanno in
solo tocco
non ci credo mi dissocio
non ho neanche toccato la strada perché
quella fare era talmente grosso che ho
colpito il cosa elettrico è stata
incredibile
ora possiamo iniziare vino io potrei
anche concluderlo poker ai boys siamo
investiti rito questo spero che non mi
scusi mi dissocio mi ha spinto stef cosa
devo fare
la rai va contro l'altro non è legale
ora che è subito l'incidente è sì ai la
kasko senza casco 6 agosto ti vedo un po
con un motore un po distrutto prova
prima di tutto direi che chiamiamo il
veicolo che utilizzerei oggi prendere in
città che è in assoluto cioè se tu pensi
alla macchina più adatta per andare in
giro per una città qual è la massima tra
il monster truck dc e quello allora però
io ti propongo questa amici ma che
chiamerà un altro vero io te lo giuro
cosa facciamo noi cerchiamo di fare le
cose legali arriva una macchina va bene
allora prego prego
questo è il suo veicolo ma cos'è
io ci provo non so quanto effettivamente
possa riuscire a restare ha però già in
pr quattro ruote scoperte sono già una
stella non ho fatto niente pensate per
pronto sulle strisce ha buona ma questa
è secondo me il video per decidere se tu
davvero meriti la patente né ho capito
ma guarda quell'altro ma la gente è il
socio mi dissocio bene non si può
iniziare questo video impossibile la
gente non vuole che io faccio a causa
legale
partiamo c'è un ritengono non c'era
perché fino a qua ci siamo che il
semaforo sergio inesatto bravi
bravissimi per poi guidare in america è
difficile perché non si sono state coin
italia e ancora non ha capito il senso
dei semafori messi così da me confondono
ma il rilascio telematico qual è quello
diritto giusto
ok meno male che non sei ste robe perché
l'ho sbagliato non ho potuto
devi girare a destra è che un capitello
l'apprezza poiché freccia dove le
vendite incentivate tagliato la strada
all albo gravità mettere nella corsia
giusta vedrai sono 50 deve girare alla
sinistra la prossima rispetto della
precedenza
ok che è la presenza sia adesso a
sinistra e cioè la macchina in america
conoscere tratti giro viscusi va bene
allora per avesse un bel 4 e mezzo ma io
sto benissimo
ok ok ok dobbiamo andare verso sinistra
ma mi venga pure nell'altra corsia
ok mi scusi mi sposto è grazie
ovviamente rosa il giallo e poi
diventano subiti farli prima sempre
fermarsi prima che arrivi il rosso
quando vedi il giallo ragazze e il
cantante posso rispondere perché sono in
macchina importante mai nel video
incredibile che stiamo facendo ci si
educa tali movimenti i limiti quando
hanno investito 7 jumping queste tredici
perfetto porta l'acqua boscomare
identità non evitato lo dice steve che
oggi rappresenta le forze dell'ordine
no ok ok della nato così va bene ora di
vedere la sinistra dove girano quelle
due auto le medie le strade peggiori
possibile va beh ovvio che se lo stop è
andato tutto a posto
che ne sai
finché non fa incidente va tutto questo
posto amici veramente sto adesso siamo
passati da 4 mesi di vita dritto e non
posso giocare per l'amor del cielo
quando ma perché si è fermato prima
avrei usare icloud è perché vi è la vita
quando quando guidi
davvero non so se tu hai la patente ma
effettivamente così piccola da molto più
tempo di te grazie di precisarlo allora
seguimi
seguendo questo voto da 1 a 10 88 non è
male ragazzi la mia vita scolastica era
molto vasto prato protetti guidando male
allora e ho bisogno di un cespuglio e
devo scappare dalla polizia
abbiamo avvio anche se rossa dai paesi
si esiste al momento siamo in pazzo
esatto il break dei criminali scusa ma
cosa dice che sono passato a sette e
mezzo e mi smontato ma tra i cespugli a
tra 60 marittimi ad arnedo malato a che
spiega allora istituti metti in questo
genere i cespugli un bug è voluta così
tu stai fermo così abituati pasta fianco
di vere apprende si rompono totalmente
si rompono e iniziano a girare attorno a
caso perché loro sanno che sono in
questa zona ma non hanno investito un
poliziotto guarda come sparando che sta
succedendo al casinò sta succedendo un
casino ve lo giuro si è tirato un
disastro ma che chiedono spazi della
guida ma vanno predicando ragazzi
bellissimi che hanno iniziato sparo
l'agente un morto uno perché tutti si è
nascosto nei cespugli e morta una
persona nella povera signora ragazzi sta
venendo delle scene che non veniva
voglio rimanere qua no vi prego vi prego
vi prego vi prego vi prego
tutto questo gioco che cos'è cosa perché
tra un po ci spareranno a casa e non ho
fatto niente sto guardando gente mib
sono investono la polizia aveva la parte
legale durata due minuti è stato vito è
diventato una caciara è emozionante però
dico questo perché avete avremo intanto
legale tale mai stato legati ci abbiamo
provato per pochissimo dai ragazzi vi
sia piaciuto cassinis casini mi
ignoranza pazienza è stata anche la
canalis thai venga di descrizione
protestare sono stati diffusi via
iscriviti al canale e da queste ciglia
hanno proseguito è la ragazza
[Musica]